before we go here's one thing you can do
today to live a happier healthier more
productive life it's part of our
partnership with Gretchen Rubin and her
award-winning podcast happier a Gallup
study finds that 67% of full-time
employees feel burned out
research shows your energy level can
affect your happiness throughout the day
New York Times bestselling author
Gretchen Rubin is here with some quick
energy boosting tips you can try right
now Gretchen good morning Khem where
this is in case you can't a list that's
the long game this is the short game
yeah so what's the first step in
improving your mood one thing that's
very easy is go outside getting light
into your face it releases brain
chemicals that boost energy and mood and
for a special boost do it first thing in
the morning that helps set our circadian
rhythm in a way that just really pays
off and exercise is a good boost as well
exercise it's great and that's even just
something like a 10-minute walk around
the block it doesn't have to be a full
workout even like 10 jumping jacks by
your desk or running down the stairs
shaking unless your mood I'm a witness
to say that does work yeah it does what
about foods okay now if you're actually
hungry like you're hangry and you need
food that's one thing but a lot of times
when we feel our energy dropping we
reach for the cookie we reach for the
sugary coffee drink and that's really
not the best way you know just jacking
yourself up on sugar it's not the best
way to get a lift you want to do
something that's healthier so this is
interesting phenomena I notice where I
have a to-do list and if I knock any
netting off of it even if it's the
smallest thing I feel reinvigorated to
do the other is completely
disproportionately right well you know
these things drain us they weigh on us
we procrastinate they just they just
overwhelm our minds and there is
something about just knocking that thing
off our list it just but what's one
thing that's helpful is to be very
specific not like just like make travel
plans but figure out the dates make the
reservations be specific with yourself I
have a turntable in my office I actually
play music sometimes yes what does that
does that contribute to this music is
one of the quickest most reliable ways
to boost our mood and so that's
something like that is wonderful having
a playlist of go-to songs it's great it
just takes a second and you get that
quick lift what about making
up your bed in the morning my husband
and I always argue over this he says
that will make you have a better day
you'll be in a better mood is that true
so many people told me that make their
bed is like the key thing they do as
crazy as that sounds
yes there's something about creating
outer order that does contribute to
inner calm and a sense of kind of energy
and focus it relieves stress partly
because you just like confined your keys
like where's my phone charger ohm -
right it's lovely to come home - and
even just making a quick like
improvement also boosts your mood when
you sort of see everything like the bed
getting made it's relaxing flowers -
yeah well good advice Gretchen Rubin
thank you very much thank you all right
that does it for us we'll see you
tomorrow here on CBS this morning thanks
everybody